we've got two hours to talk about
everything happening in the national
football league and you never know where
the news is going to come from and
there's a story that has been the result
chris of a sequence of events and let's
take you back to last week it began with
a tweet from leonard fournette
advocating for the jaguars to add cam
newton of course the only problem is i
already have gardner minshew the second
well then leonard fournette was on espn
and he elaborated on his position that
cam newton should become a jaguar cam
went to the super bowl fournette said
he's a great guy i've been knowing cam
for a minute now
which i think means i'm not nearly hip
enough for this i think it means i've
known him for a long time it's no
disrespect to gardner minshew i'm just
trying to get in the best position as a
team as we can to win
that's
all that was about just friendly
competition because that brings out the
best in people so no disrespect to
gardner minshew but obviously when
you're arguing for cam newton to join
the team chris you don't want cam newton
to be the backup to garter men's shoe
you want cam newton to be the starter if
you were gardner minshew how would you
react to that message from
leonard fournette
well you know with a guy like gardner
mitchell who first off we know has is a
great guy is liked by the jacksonville
fan base and the organization obviously
so they're going with them uh but also
if i put myself in gardner minshews
shoes i also sit there and go huh i
haven't done anything yet i don't have a
lot of pelts on my horse right yet to
sit here and go i'm the man i'm the
starting quarterback of a franchise
nobody should come in here and challenge
me you shall not pass no i mean i don't
think he's earned that right yet all
right to just feel like he's warm and
cozy now can he sit there and go man i
wish leonard fournette had a little more
you know confidence in me and you know
wanted me to be the guy yeah sure but i
think gardner-menchu and we've been
around him now right i think he gets it
i mean there's a guy like cam newton on
out on the street right now who won an
mvp who's been dominant in the nfl for a
long long time so this is not personal
if i'm gardner minchu i'm kind of like
ah this is kind of messed up you've said
this and made it public i don't like
that aspect of it because now you start
to get those rumors going and oh is
leonard fournette unhappy but i think
all in all gardner minshew will be able
to be realistic about the situation and
and be able to handle like a
professional i don't think he'll be
personally hurt by it mike
so that came up in the middle of the
week chris and coincidentally doug
marone the jaguars coach was on lunch
talk live with mike tarico on friday
and marone had a chance to talk about
his starting running back musing
publicly about the possibility of
bringing in cam newton to supplant
gardner minshew here's marone from
friday
you know with players you're always
going to have friends like hey get you
know this guy should come and that guy
should come and you know you try to talk
to the players about talking about the
team and doing what's best and keeping a
single message but then a lot of times
you're gonna have to be able to
communicate in that locker room i mean
that's the big thing with me i mean we
all talk about hey we're all men and
everything and you know when you're in a
lot of people say hey listen i said this
because i really think that this is you
know best for the team and if you can't
say this is what's best for the team
you know then you're going to have
issues and then things can you know can
spiral
to a point where you can't get in
that's marooned with mike tarico from
friday and i like that very pragmatic
approach by doug marone you have to make
sure that these two guys fernette and
minshu work it out and if marone needs
to help facilitate that so be it but
then came the next development in this
story that is now lingered for several
days a report from espn on saturday and
i confirmed this yesterday the jaguars
are looking to trade leonard fournette
who had chris 1
674 yards from scrimmage last year his
best season yet in the nfl for a team
that didn't really have a great passing
game because minshu was getting up to
speed after nick foles got injured and
then minchu got kind of benched when
folz was healthy and then foles got
benched again for minshew meanwhile
fournette was the most steady and
productive member of the offense they're
looking to trade him he's got a
guaranteed salary of 4.1 million
this year i guess i'm not
shocked by this
but at the same time
that had a pretty solid year right
and i think at the core here's here's
what a source told me yesterday and i
heard this from multiple different
people who understand the dynamics leona
fournette and this is the quote i'm
gonna go ahead and say it is a pain in
the ass and there's only so much you can
take when dealing with a pain in the ass
especially at a position like running
back where there are plenty of other
guys out there that you can find maybe
in the draft this week who can come in
and get it done so
4.1 million when you consider what the
broncos are paying melvin gordon 8
million what the cardinals are paying
kenyan drake 8.48 million 4.1 million
for 2020 with an option for 2021 at 8.48
million if you pick it up by may 3rd
that's a bargain for a guy who has been
a high-end producer at least based upon
what we saw from him last year
well he's a really good football player
you said that and you're right i mean
he's he's probably right outside the top
five running backs in football when you
really get into that conversation now
you know added to the fact you mentioned
it the draft is deep at running back we
know that there's going to be a lot of
guys go in the second third and fourth
rounds so you could certainly fill holes
that way right we know the jacksonville
jaguars even though leonard fournette
like you're saying mike is the best
probably offensive player on their
football team i don't think there's any
denying that right now they got some
other good ones too like dj shark and
some of the receivers but i think he's
probably the most consistent proven
commodity on their offense
and they're in a rebuild mode so they're
stuck in okay yes it'd be nice to have a
good tailback but we can get others
we're in rebuild mode right now
obviously with what they've been doing
yannick and gawkway of being on the
trade market everything there
then leonard fournette getting towards
the end of his rookie contract which
you're right it's very favorable right
now but also the balance is oh we might
be able to strike and get the most for
him right now with teams maybe going
over in the draft evaluation process we
need these two or three positions really
bad and i also need running back man i
can make a trade right now and get the
running back and then maybe i can use
those draft assets to use the other
position
needs i i have on my football team to
get filled so i think there's that
aspect mike and then last thing because
i'm sorry for the long answer but
leonard fournette has proven to be a
little bit of a pain in the butt there
there's no doubt whether it was running
on the field of buffalo and getting
involved in a fight across the field
there's been a few other instances plus
he runs violently and he's had a little
injury history and i'm sure all those
things are the reasons we're hearing
about him on the trade market right now
yeah and not to mention publicly
lobbying for cam newton to join the
jaguars at a time when it's obvious of
course the team is shifting its focus to
gardner minshew as the starting
quarterback and hoping to give him a
full and fair opportunity to be the guy
now look i
i know that whenever we talk about the
jaguars now the word rebuild comes up i
don't think that they view it that way
in part because the owner shot khan
isn't going to be patient with doug
marone and dave caldwell this is the old
change the tire on a moving car recently
effort and and it's cultural as much as
anything chris getting rid of guys that
really don't buy in getting rid of guys
that may be inclined to be a pain in the
butt and also i can't help but wonder is
the offense going to look different this
year with jay gruden there as the
coordinator are they going to open it up
are they going to throw it around more
do they not need between the tackles
violent downhill runner that could maybe
fit better somewhere else so all those
things considered the jaguars trying to
get what they can for fournette and if
they can't get anything they really like
look they're still on the back burner a
grievance over whether or not his
guarantees were avoided when he was
suspended during that bills game or
after that bill's game for his actions
during the bills game back in 2018 that
could heat up again they could cut him
and end up owing him nothing for this
year if they can't trade him but i'd
like to think at 4.1 million they can
find somebody to take on a guy who had
1674 rushing yards and put him on a team
where you will have the coaching and the
veteran leadership to get him to not be
a pain in the butt and chris i here's
your opportunity to call me crazy we
have been talking about the kansas city
chiefs needing an upgrade at the
tailback position they were looking into
le'veon bell last year according to bell
when the trade deadline was approaching
think about leonard fournette as a guy
who could be
the balance to that chief's passing
offense as the guy who can contribute in
the passing game he had over 500
receiving yards last year even though he
is viewed as a downhill violent physical
runner do you
have any
positivity in your being when i suggest
leonard fournette as a possible kansas
city chief where he would have andy reid
who would maybe know how to press the
buttons to get the most out of him and
more importantly a guy who grew up in
the same neighborhood as leonard at new
orleans and who went to the same college
as leonard fournette entirely matthew
get him pointed in the right direction
and get him to stop being a pain in the
butt and get the most out of his
physical attributes what do you say
well i i don't think it's totally crazy
okay first off i mean i think you're
totally crazy
in a tired looking crazy on monday just
to add that in there
you're welcome
but i i think all your points are real
you know i do and first off if he is you
know listen i don't look at leonard
fournette and go oh man he's a problem
this guy's a real pain in the butt no i
don't look at him that way i think he's
a young guy who's emotional and was a
part of a team where
they let the players emotions kind of
run the team a little bit there in
jacksonville for a little while and i
think he got out of hand now you want to
check somebody before they wreck
somebody yeah you go to a team that just
won the super bowl and they realize oh
wow they don't really need me here right
just like we talk about with new england
all the time that'll set somebody
straight plus players are usually
excited to go to a team like that
because they're going wow i've been in
jacksonville we had one good season i'm
dying to win some football games do any
of that the tyrone matthew uh connection
there mike very real that would
certainly encourage me if i was kansas
city and thinking about that you know
and leonard fournette like i said he can
catch the ball in the backfield he's
he's a freak of nature okay i don't
think people realize how good leonard
fournette is he got stuck in
jacksonville
with blake bortles who couldn't throw
the football and people put nine people
at the line of scrimmage for the first
three years of his career all within
four feet of the line of scrimmage
because they just said no blake bortles
isn't gonna beat us so it's never looked
as sexy and as good statistically and
highlight wise because they've never had
a pass game to worry about since he's
been there as a starting running back
and it's hard to thrive there so i do
understand that thought mike and i don't
think you're totally crazy
other teams that i've considered and
before i move on let me show you this
damian williams who had a very good
performance in the super bowl we had 498
rushing yards last year for the chiefs
now i know andy reid doesn't have a
reputation as being a guy who
establishes the run and sticks with the
run and runs and runs and runs but under
500 yards for your leading rusher not
encouraging and they look at those birds
and they paid lesean mccoy three million
dollars last year and what did they get
out of him for three million you can get
leonard for never 4.1 that seems like a
good trade but i try i went through all
the divisions every team and i tried to
be broad in who i thought should be
interested or could be interested in
fournette how about the steelers right
wouldn't he be isn't that one of those
moves where
the moment they got him we would say
well we should have been thinking of the
steelers all along
but it's the first name that came this
first team that came to my head was the
pittsburgh steelers i mean when i read
the articles on pft and some of this
going down i went oh man first off he'd
look really good in black and yellow
they need that type of runner there
especially hey it's you know james
connor i like him i don't think he's a
starting superstar type tailback i think
he's a great guy to have as your backup
but also with big ben coming off of the
elbow injury and getting up there in
years i mean i don't know if you're the
steeler you can go into the year and go
we can win games just throwing the ball
40 times a game with big ben i love big
ben you know i think he's as underrated
as hell when the all-time lures of this
sport he's a great player but he is that
age and i would think that would be
something they would entertain now the
big thing is pittsburgh you know they've
traded some assets away to get players
like minka fitzpatrick do they have the
the ass and devin bush last year in the
first round do they have the assets do
they want to trade more of those assets
away to get a running back where hey as
you and i both know it only might be a
three or four year gig before his career
is over or certainly on the down
downhill side of uh of things
it was jerome bettis who got started in
la with the rams before he was traded to
the steelers we don't think of him as a
ram we think of him as a steeler and
that's exactly what would happen with
fournette who as a rookie was with the
jaguars went to pittsburgh twice that
year regular season he had 181 rushing
yards including a 90 yard touchdown
which will help you get to 181 if you
have 90 on one play and then in the
playoffs went back to pittsburgh and won
and had 109 yards against pittsburgh so
they have seen up close what he can do
to their defense a couple of other teams
that came to mind for me and again this
is just spit balling the eagles really
don't have that between the terrorist
presence i know i know miles sanders
aspires to be christian mccaffrey but
become christian mccarthy before you
start talking about being christian
mccaffrey and also the rams what do the
rams really have without todd gurley
they're hoping some guys step up but
we'll see but you know they're they're r
and that was the widest net possible i
thought about the saints at one point
until i looked at latavius murray's
contract they're into him for three
million plus fully guaranteed this year
chris so i don't think the saints would
be in on it but
he'd be to alvin kamara if they could do
it financially there just aren't a lot
of teams out there that have the need
but to me chief steelers eagles rams
would be the four
that stand out is there anyone that i'm
missing
no i i like your four there i agree with
it very much i'm gonna say this one more
time okay
i think the buffalo bills should look at
it i know devin singletary's really good
i get it he's not a bell cow running
back and you know mike i'm into what was
there to be had he ran through a lot of
big holes last year okay and i'm not
gonna sit here and just go oh man i'm so
impressed with what i saw from him he's
really good but you know they got a big
powerful offensive line you got to play
in some weather conditions up there in
buffalo i think he would fit there that
would jump out to me a little bit and
even the indianapolis colts but mike
this guy's a freak there's a reason he
was a top five pick and back to your
pittsburgh moment you know that year
when he had that 90 yard touchdown that
was like next gen stats he was the
fastest guy in football that year nobody
had more miles per hour than one run or
play than anybody in the sport not even
tyree kill and leonard fournette's 230
something pounds so that's what type of
specimen he is i think we hit all the
teams uh but i do i look at buffalo
sometimes and the colts is a little bit
of an outside chance just because i
think fournette's special
and i remember his first year at lsu he
landed on our radar screen and we all
looked and said this guy's going to be
great at the next level it tailed off a
little bit then it took a couple of
years to get going but 1674 yards from
scrimmage last year and it's amazing the
number of people who write him off
because he wasn't a star right away in
the nfl and because he wasn't the guy
after his freshman season at lsu that he
was but 1674 speaks for itself on a team
that didn't have a high-end passing game
all right take a break
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports